[Music]
hi everyone thank you so much for coming
i hope you're having a great time at
next
my name is ali rutzel and i'm a senior
manager of user experience at google
i work on a new enterprise video meeting
experience and hangouts which you're
going to be hearing a little bit more
about tomorrow in the keynote
so i'm here today to give you a
behind-the-scenes look into google's
usability design philosophy and how you
can apply what you've learned here at
your organization
i'll also be happy to answer questions
at the end of the session there'll be
plenty of time i think i timed myself
and this only took 30 minutes
so
i really do want to hear from you
so if you have questions please feel
free to ask them at the end
so first
what exactly do i mean when i say
usability
a leading expert in the field defines
usability as a quality attribute that
assesses how easy user interfaces are to
use
that's pretty straightforward but it's
also an oversimplification the word
usability can also refer to methods we
employ for improving ease of use during
the design process and i'll talk a
little bit more about that in a minute
but for now let's talk about usability
and break it down into what i consider
it six quality components
so learnability how easy is it for users
to accomplish basic tasks the first time
they encounter a design
the more learnable a system is the less
time a user takes in order to understand
how to do a specific task without having
been previously trained or provided
documentation
but how important is learnability in a
design
think about if you're designing a user
interface for a kiosk in a mall
you want people to be able to go up to
it and accomplish their tasks really
quickly they don't have to learn how to
use the interface you want them to
achieve their goals and get out of the
way so learnability is incredibly
important in that scenario but if you're
working on let's say a really complex
enterprise business system for customer
service management tools
um
then the chances are that they're more
likely going to invest more time in
learning how to use the system
and maybe there's training involved so
really the point is that learnability in
that case is still important
but other components of usability may be
a higher priority
efficiency is another component of
usability
once users have learned the design how
quickly can they perform the tasks
efficiency is typically measured by the
number of clicks or keystrokes required
or the total time on task
but once again it's important to
understand your users and how they like
to work
for example are they likely to use the
interface infrequently
or are they going to be habitual users
that are in it every day
maybe they're going to learn hidden
shortcuts and
the controls shortcuts can be extremely
efficient for the proficient users
um but
those that have to use the interface a
little bit less often
if shortcuts are the primary interaction
tool they're going to be really slowed
down by that because they're not going
to understand what those are and they're
going to have to learn them
memorability
when users return to the design after a
period of not using it how easily can
they re-establish proficiency
think about how often users will be
coming back to your product or service
obviously we all want them to come every
single day but chances are that they're
not going to do that
well some people will but most often
they won't
um for example i have diamond status on
delta but i don't go to the delta site
every single day
but when i do it's important that i know
where to find things i want them to be
in the same place that they were before
so obviously a design that's complicated
is going to make it harder for users to
remember the exact steps that they took
to accomplish the task
which is why efficiency and memorability
actually go hand in hand
if the design is more efficient then
they're going to be less steps for them
to go through to accomplish their tasks
and less things to remember
this makes it easier for them to
re-establish proficiency
even after a long period of not having
used the product
so accessibility i think this one is
really important can all users
regardless of ability
navigate understand and achieve their
goals equally without barriers
in the words of nicolas zakis a
front-end engineer former front-end
engineer at yahoo
accessibility is not a feature
and i think that's really important to
take into consideration
this means that accessibility is not an
optional item on a list of product
functions
but instead a mandatory requirement on
par with performance
as such
every product should be built with
accessibility in mind from the very
beginning
while accessibility focuses on people
with disabilities
many accessibility requirements actually
improve the usability for everybody so
accessibility especially benefits people
that have uh that don't have
disabilities but are in limiting
situations um
so imagine you know
that time i broke my hand slamming it in
a car door and i wasn't able to use the
device the way that i normally would and
i had to turn on accessibility features
to be able to navigate
or even being outside in the sunlight
with a phone or a laptop where you're
limited by the contrast on the screen so
there are a lot of things that we call
situational
disabilities that we need to be thinking
about when we're designing our tools
errors
how many errors do users make and how
severe are these errors
and how easily can they recover from
them
errors are on a you know they're they're
inevitable they happen unintended
actions happen think about how many
times you're filling in a form maybe you
mistyped your email address put in the
wrong password
a lot of times i when i'm filling out my
credit card expiration date i put the
wrong month in and i get a big error and
i have to go back and redo it
but there's a difference between these
types of slips and user interface
problems
if users continue to click on a heading
that's not actually clickable
or they try to look for something in the
wrong part of your navigation system
then there's probably something about
the design
that we can improve
one action is to take one action to take
is to make sure all of the elements in
you in your ui are instrumented for
performance metrics so that you can
understand what people are doing when
they use your product
and if you don't know what people are
doing
the whatevers they're making you're not
going to be able to be to fix it
so
a lot of times we just look at
performance metrics for things that
are pretty standard but think about the
elements of your ui
that
you want you might not know that people
are clicking on but they are clicking on
it the non-clickable things like that
header that i talked about you might not
instrument it because it's not a click
but if people think it is you want to
know that too
and finally satisfaction
satisfaction
i consider is probably the hardest to
measure satisfaction is about how
pleasant is it to use your design
often
how often have you been on a site when
all of a sudden you're trying to
accomplish a task all of a sudden this
like satisfaction survey pops up like a
weird
thing that you know it kind of just
jumps in your face and interrupts your
flow
first of all that's not very satisfying
but uh
but think about it we people use that
businesses use that because they want to
know what you think
so we have to find ways of asking our
users what they think without being so
kind of annoying
you can do this in usability studies a
lot of people will actually use
usability studies as a way to gather
that qualitative information
and that's great i love usability
studies uh we do them all the time but
sometimes we notice that participants
tend to rate an interface highly on
post-test
questionnaires even when they fail to
complete the task
and the reason they do that is for uh
there are a couple reasons one
they kind of want to impress you
they they want you know hey i'm here i
can really do this it's great you know
they don't want to say anything negative
to you um sometimes you're you're paying
them to participate in the study so they
feel like they have to please you
but the worst one the one that makes me
cringe is that they often blame
themselves
that it wasn't it wasn't the ui's
problem it was my fault that i failed
and so they don't want to um they don't
want to like show that that was their
fault they want to say you know
everything was great it was wonderful
not you it's me
so unless they're carefully worded uh
and another thing we use is surveys but
unless they're carefully worded surveys
can also result in what we call
acquiescence bias
the fact that people are more likely to
agree with the statement then disagree
with the statement
so those satisfaction surveys or those
4c surveys or whatever you'll notice
that they're carefully crafted so that
they're not biased or leading
so it's hard but it's not impossible
good user researchers know the proper
methodologies to use for measuring
satisfaction and i'll talk a little bit
about how we do that in a minute
but now that you know how we think about
usability
the components of which are learnability
efficiency
memorability
accessibility
errors and satisfaction let me share a
little bit more about our usability
philosophy at google
it's pretty simple
focus on the user and all else will
follow
so how do we do that how do we focus on
the user
we do it by involving the user in every
phase of product development
when we think about the phases of
product development we typically think
of a temporal progression from idea to
launch some of you have may seen this
framework before it's often referred to
as the double diamond
during the discover and planning phases
we're trying to figure out what the
right thing is to build this phase is
divergent and exploratory
it's a search for new questions
before we start to then synthesize
knowledge into an insight that's why we
go wide before we start to go narrow
in the remaining phases of conceptual
design detail design and build
we're focused on designing
the right the designing the thing right
we take the insights that we learned in
the first phase
and we explore several solutions and
then we narrow it down
and craft the working solution that we
plan to bring to market
this linear path helps us feel like
we're making progress
but as you probably already know if
you've ever done product development
this is not how things typically go
this is what the process looks like for
real
yeah this is more like it
the reality is the process is really
messy
you have an idea you try it out you
argue about it you mock it up maybe you
test it out on a few users you realize
that they don't like it or there's
something wrong with it so you try
something else
then maybe you realize that there are
technical difficulties and the back end
can't support what you're doing and
makes it infeasible so you have to loop
back somewhere near the beginning and
start again and somewhere in there
there's coffee and beer
but your goals are still the same
you want to design the right thing
and design the thing right
in other words you want it to address
user needs
and you want it to be usable
so let's dive into these phases and see
how you can keep the user at the center
of this messy process how you can focus
on the user
so during the discover phase
you wanted to uncover opportunities for
design improvement
if that if you have an existing product
if you have a brand new product that
you're just working on you also want to
start looking at the market
and understanding the the needs that are
out there that aren't being fulfilled
this phase should be a really close
partnership between ux engineering and
product management but you should also
involve operations support marketing
sales
any other specialists in the
organization
that talk to the your users so that you
can gather as much data as possible
about them
the goal here is to understand user
needs
understand who your users are and how
they currently use your product
qualitative quantitative research like
metrics and log analysis
really helps you understand the what of
people are doing
what users are doing when they're using
your product
but qualitative research such as
ethnographic studies which is going out
into the field and actually observing
users in their natural environment
sounds like diane fossey but it is it's
about going out there and meeting them
where they work seeing the environment
that they work in
that helps you uncover the why behind
the what
sun and sometimes the y can surprise you
so i'm going to take a little aside and
tell you a funny story that my husband
told me long ago
he's a my husband's a fiber optic
engineer and
there was a time when a customer
complained about temporary outages that
were happening
around the same time each day and so he
would look at the data and he would see
yeah like there's like a brief outage
and it seems to happen in the afternoon
and they ran tests and diagnostics and
they couldn't really figure out why this
was happening
he sent technicians out to the field to
look for those usual suspects apparently
squirrels like to gnaw on the wires and
that can cause outages so they looked
for a little phrase and everything like
that they couldn't find anything
so he was becoming really frustrated
because he couldn't figure out what was
wrong
so what he decided to do is he sent a
technician over to the customer site one
day
and he went out in the truck with
another technician and they just kind of
like went around the area where the
outage was happening it's hard to
pinpoint down exactly where it is
and something happened he noticed a
little boy about 10 years old walking
home from school he had a stick in his
hand
and as they were walking as he was
walking down the street
he approaches what's called a down guy
and that's the when you think about a
telephone pole and the way it anchors to
the ground that that um
uh angular wire that's called a down guy
he would take that stick as he
approached it and he would give it a
good thwack
and what was happening
was that the vibration of the wire was
interrupting the light path of the
optical cable and so while it was
vibrating the outage happened and then
it would stabilize and the outage would
stop
so sure enough
moments after the kid thwacks that line
my husband gets a call customer has an
outage
so
he went to the kid and he's like do you
do this every day
and the kid's like yeah i like the sound
it makes when i hit it because it does
it likes to make this weird hum
and he's like
oh my god we figured it out and so my
point is that there are some problems
that you'll never really understand
until you actually go out in the field
and observe what people are doing
so
let me give you an example of what we've
experienced on my own product in this
area
so in 2013 hangouts was a part of g plus
through logs analysis we noticed that it
was becoming increasingly popular among
business users so we reached out to them
to find out more we want to know why
we conducted diary studies and field
research with local businesses
and based on what they told us and what
we observed we were able to uncover some
interesting insights that led to
opportunities to improve the experience
for them
one thing we saw was that there were
basically four types of meetings
where they used hangouts
the first is ad hoc these are your
typical pickup meetings these are the
ones like hey i have a really quick
question do you want to jump on a
hangout and answer it
let's go into this quick room let me
show you something
round tables are what we think of as the
more traditional typical meetings
they're usually scheduled sometimes
they're recurring think about like your
team meetings um or where you go into
some review something or solve a problem
structured engagements are more like
sales presentations or trainings this is
where there's usually one speaker and
he's presenting to a group
and then spotlights which are generally
larger meetings
they're more like all hands and earning
reports where you have one to many
they're often broadcast to a large
audience that might be remote or
watching online
our customers are using hangouts on air
for things like that
so once we got insight into
why and how hangouts customers were
using the product we were able to
conceive of a new enterprise focused
take on video meetings that could better
meet their needs
so the second phase of the design
process is or the product development
process is planning this is about
clarifying and outlining nuances of the
problem
the goals here are about taking what you
learned and deciding on the right thing
to build
some methods that you can use to help
you decide are
just prioritizing the user problems or
creating use cases and scenarios to help
you understand like when somebody does
something what are the scenarios they're
doing it in and what are they trying to
accomplish
one thing that we also do on my team is
what we call a strategy brief or a
one-pager
and this is before the prd this is when
you're first sitting down and thinking
about the problem
it doesn't get into detail but instead
it aligns the team
on the high level goals
helps you identify and narrow down who
it is that you're trying to who is your
user and who it is that you're trying to
reach and also defines what success
looks like because without that north
star
you can often like your ux team your pm
team your engineers might all have
different end goals in mind and you
might not be aligned so we found like a
one pager very simple sit down talk
about these things at a high level and
make sure you're all on the same page
in my and the last method here is
experience mapping and i'm going to talk
about that in my last example i
mentioned that we decided to focus on
the solving the user needs of the common
round table meeting type first because
that was something that we felt most of
our users were
were doing but we didn't understand what
exactly they needed
so to figure that out we decided to
create an experience map of a typical
meeting
so what is an experience map
this is pretty simplified but an
experience map is a strategic process of
capturing and communicating interfaces
or interactions from a user's
perspective
in this example i'm showing a really
simplified version of the experience map
that we created when developing our new
product
but what we structured the map to do is
look at when you think about meetings
there are different stages of meetings
there's the before the meeting during
the meeting and after the meeting
and on the y-axis we have what are users
doing what are the tasks that they're
actually doing
during those phases what are they
thinking while they're doing those
things how are they feeling
during those those actions
and then what are those opportunities
that the the product can um
uh what do we see as opportunities for
solving some of those user needs
so for example in the before phase we
found out that business users were often
needing to take meetings when they were
on the road
so as you know internet connections can
be pretty spotty so under opportunities
we decided to put provide dial-in access
to meetings so that they could use their
phone rather than have to rely on video
so you can also add a section for gaps
that's all that's pretty common so you
can look at what the gaps are in your
product versus the market
but
this is a really helpful process for
just really laying out the landscape
of what your user is doing in and around
your product
since meetings are spatial as well as
temporal we also had to consider a
variety of physical factors when
creating our map
for example before a meeting begins you
probably need to find the room so what
does the way finding system look like
how confused are you going to be about
getting there
how do you know how long it's going to
take you to get there
and then when you're in the room you
need to use a remote to actually start
the meeting and maybe control some of
the things like zooming and muting
so there are a lot of physical elements
that we had to think about as well
a lot of times the remote goes missing
in those rooms and then what do you do
then
so the activity of mapping an experience
like this really helps organizations
identify strategic opportunities
customer pain points
and helps us generate innovative
products
it also helps you decide on where to
focus your energy before moving to the
conceptual design phase
so conceptual design is where you create
the most app solution for the problem
it's where you
you're entering this phase when you
understand what the problem is but you
don't know yet how to solve it
so from talking to our users and
creating the experience map we
discovered that joining a video meeting
can be pretty painful process but we
didn't really know exactly how to solve
that in this phase our goal is
creativity we really want to generate a
lot of ideas no ideas are stupid in this
phase
and then we start testing and iterating
on them
we want to design the thing right
a great way to involve the user in this
phase is to do rapid iterative
prototyping
and quick usability testing it doesn't
have to be on end users it can be with
people on your team it can be with the
sales department it can be with anybody
nearby
you really just want to get ideas out
there and try and validate them as
quickly as possible as to which is the
one that you want to move forward with
my advice here is to stay low fidelity
and i'm talking sketches wireframes
rough user flows this is about the idea
not the execution
the lower the fidelity the better
actually
even when testing with users paper
prototypes are really helpful
we've learned that
as the fidelity of the wireframes and
and prototypes goes up
the quality of the feedback actually can
go down because people are hesitant to
give you negative feedback
when they think that you've actually put
a lot of effort into it so sometimes
even if we work in high fidelity we'll
dumb it down we'll make it a little bit
less polished so when we put it in front
of people they feel a little bit more
comfortable in providing feedback on the
product
so here's an example of what we showed
users early on as i mentioned for video
meetings it's critical that attendees
can join quickly and easily so we shared
our ideas for several different ways
that they could set up a meeting
so our options to them were hey you can
have it be totally open so anybody with
a link to the meeting can join
if someone is not invited or outside the
company's domain you can require them to
knock to get in
or you could choose to completely lock
it down so it's only open to people who
are on the calendar in invitation no
exceptions
so we tested these concepts and people
just couldn't grasp all the different
options and why they had to make a
choice how do i know which one is right
what if i'm wrong why shouldn't i be
able to set it up you know one way and
change it the next time so we wrangled
with several text changes to try and
make everything more clear
but ultimately we decided to just come
up with a simple default where if you're
not explicitly invited to the meeting
you can knock to get in
we found that users expect us to do the
right thing and this was a great moment
when we realized usability research can
influence the product direction
the detailed design phase
is where you spec the complete
end-to-end solution so once we knew
conceptually where we wanted to go
we entered this phase to nail down the
details
this is about getting the details right
so your final product is delightful and
easy to use
it's about holding a high bar for
quality and about making sure the
experience is consistent so users don't
have to relearn something
they maybe knew how to do or should
already be familiar with
an example that i can pull from google
is when you think about how you share
something in docs sheets or slides
you know where that is and it always
behaves the same way so why reinvent the
wheel especially if it's part of a suite
of products
this is where the designers on your team
are doing the visual polish and the
redlining or what we call specking out
down to the pixel of how the ui should
look and behave for your engineers to
build
this is also a phase where you really
want to make sure your accessibility
spec
is up to date to determine how screen
readers are going to be able to
interpret your pages
for our new
video meeting product during this phase
we also did an extensive audit of what
we call critical user journeys and
that's the last method on here and i'll
talk about those right now
so users don't think
in terms of single features
they think in terms of accomplishing
tasks
tasks often involve multiple features
products or product areas
thus they journey through the hardware
and the software
simply put a user journey is a task that
a user wants to perform
and a critical user journey is the
really important jersey that you have to
get right
at google we identified two types of
critical user journeys
toothbrush journeys are what we call the
common tasks that people perform often
and pivotal journeys
are less frequent but also important
tasks such as when you're asking someone
to sign in or use the product for the
first time they're not likely to go
through that again but you gotta get it
right the first time
in my example our journey was
as a first-time user i want to join my
next meeting right now
this journey forced us to take a step
back and think about what it's like to
experience our product for the first
time
and acknowledge the options for joining
could be a little overwhelming and
confusing
critical user journeys frequently cross
uh product and feature boundaries
at a minimum
at a minimum level you should be aware
of how what you're working on fits into
the bigger picture
with video meetings for example we had
to think about how this uh integrated
into calendaring and chat systems so
that people could quickly move from chat
to video
um
uh or move from a calendar into a video
we wanted to make sure the experience
was going to be excellent for our users
so we spent a full week going through
our critical user journeys and doing an
audit to document the potential pitfalls
we scrutinized 30 journeys just like
this one
and we looked at them across all of
devices we looked at the ios and android
apps we looked at the tv experience when
you're in a conference room we looked at
the web we also looked at it through a
number of different lenses we had people
looking at the visual design aspect the
interaction design the motion the audio
cues and accessibility
and writing we even had our writer take
a look so every single person was doing
a pass to make sure that that aspect of
the experience was the best that it
could be
we filed bugs even if a visual design
was a pixel or two off we were pretty
strict
so you can really do critical user
journeys at any time during the design
process um ideally you want to actually
start thinking about what those critical
user journeys on early
um so that you're part of maybe when
you're doing your user stories and
scenarios
but in our case we had to find them in
the planning phase
but we did the audit in the detail
design phase before we were ready to
start
going to to launch
and then finally the build phase
this is where we implement test and
evaluate the solution
the goals of the build phase
are about pride and craftsmanship
attention to detail
testing and launching
and assessing the implementation once
it's launched
as for the methods you want to make sure
that you've instrumented the site using
tools like google analytics or whatever
your preferred one is for performance
and usability metrics remember when we
talked about the components of usability
in the beginning
you want to be confident that you're
capturing data like number of clicks
errors and more
you also want to run experiments such as
a b tests to see which design is
performing better for your users
but most importantly you want to engage
in what we call
data informed design not data driven
design
when you're data driven you're only
following the quantitative results of
your research
the famous example at google is the 41
shades of blue when we tested literally
41 shades of blue links on the search
page to see which one performed better
you can look it up i'm not kidding
and
that's great you know we saw actual
different results
when we looked at all the different
shades of blue but that's
that's a bit soulless
it's not the way that we want to think
about using data in our design process
um
when you're data driven you only follow
you're only looking at the at the hard
data but that data can sometimes be
misleading because it'll tell you the
what but not the why and understanding
the why is where you are able to take
action
instead use the data and combine it with
qualitative feedback
to assess the complete picture
this is data informed sign
quantitative metrics are also not often
useful for evaluating the impact of the
ux changes that you make
this is because they're pretty general
they don't usually directly relate to
either the quality of the user
experience or the goals of your product
so it's hard to make them actionable
so to help with this a few smart
researchers at google came up with a
method that we called heart
the heart framework is useful for
evaluating
evaluating
the quality of the user experience and
the impact of ux changes over time
happiness
measures user attitudes often collected
via those surveys we talked about
for example satisfaction surveys
perceived ease of use net promoter score
is a good example
engagement measures the level
of user involvement
typically via behavioral proxies such as
frequency
intensity or depth of interaction over
the some time period
examples might include the number of
visits per user per week or the number
of photos uploaded uploaded per user per
day
for hangouts we want to know how often
people are creating video meetings and
maybe how long those meetings are
adoption
measures the number of new users of a
product or feature
for example you want to in this one you
want to look at the the number of new
users that are creating accounts
um
maybe over a period of time like
accounts created in the last seven days
or the percentage of new users who
create
video meetings
retention is the rate at which existing
users are returning to your product
for example how many of the active users
from a given time period are still
present sometime later in the time in
the same time period you might be more
interested in uh failure to retain which
is what we commonly known as commonly
known as churn
and then task success
includes the traditional behavioral
metrics
um
these include efficiency the time to
complete a task effectiveness
the percent of tasks completed
and the error rate that we discussed
earlier this category is most applicable
to areas
of your product where they're very task
focused as such as like doing a search
or an upload flow
so we're often asked why measure
adoption and retention when you can just
count unique users
it's definitely important to count how
many users you had in a given time
period for example seven day actives
but if you measure adoption and
retention as well you're going to be
explicitly distinguishing new users from
returning users
so you can tell how quickly your user
base is growing
or stabilizing
this is especially useful for new
products and features or those being
redesigned
now you don't necessarily need to create
metrics in all these categories you
should choose the ones that are most
important for your particular project
however no matter what type of metric
you choose there's one important
principle
that you always want to stick to
you want to ensure that the metrics are
in line with the user goals that you
defined for your product
so to wrap up
usability is about keeping the user at
the center of your product development
process
you want to consider the learnability
the efficiency the memorability the
accessibility
errors and satisfaction
inherent in your product
i shared some of the methods that we use
at google like experience mapping and
heart metrics
which i hope you found useful and and
you can obviously try in your own
organizations
um we've touched at very high levels um
on on some of these methods and so i
encourage you to look and find
um resources uh on your own in the web
uh these are some of these are fairly
well known some of these are are
more inherent to google's culture
but
i really just hope that if you learned
one thing here today it's how important
it is to involve the user when you're
building products if you want them to
use them and trust them and love them
and since you're all google's users
you can also be a part of our design
process
so get involved if you're a g suite
administrator or an end user of our
tools you can sign up
to be a part of our g suite user panel
if you're a developer or cloud platform
user you can sign up as well for our
google cloud platform panel i'll leave
this up for a bit if you guys want to
take a snapshot
i also want to use this time to promote
a session coming up
in the next room i think it's room
number eight it's it's coming up right
after this it's titled uh driving
product excellence with user feedback
which will go deeper into our research
practices and our trusted tester and
early adopter programs so if you want to
learn more about that and and the
activities that we do around
actually going on site and talking to to
our customers that's a great session to
go to
late last year we used our trusted
tester program to validate key features
of our products such as supporting
larger meeting sizes and making it
easier to join meetings by phone or
video
these weren't just ux issues they were
essential for us to know whether we had
a product market fit
we also invited several particularly
engaged large customers to have a seat
at the table during the design process
we visited some of those testers to
watch how the product was used in action
providing valuable insights to improve
our usability
so thank you so much for coming to next
and coming to my session
[Music]
[Music]